Richard's in Arizona do you have any
tips on getting my significant other on
board we've been together for about ten
years and for the past four years I've
been making good money but nothing to
show for it all she wants to do is take
vacations and go out to eat Richard
you're probably not gonna like my advice
but I'll give it to you anyway because
you asked here's the thing I answer
questions on this show what would I do
if I were in your shoes and I have read
I don't know 20 25 studies with all
kinds of data points in them that
indicate all of them conclusively that
people who are married get along better
than people who are shacked up when it
comes to money and people who are
married versus being shacked up actually
statistically become wealthier on
average now there's exceptions obviously
but there's a tremendous data out there
that talks about the benefits of
marriage now I look at that through as a
Christian through a moral lens as well
but that's not what I'm talking about
here I'm talking about just the
practical data points that say that your
relationship functions better in that
situation it's a little different
telling your girlfriend what to do then
it is your wife it's a little different
telling your husband what to do then
your boyfriend or when something's
important to you I think we should do
this but there's not really a we I think
we need to get on a budget and we need
to save for retirement but there's not
really a we not legally speaking and for
that matter not spiritually speaking and
data so is not relationally speaking
you're just that you leave yourself at a
disadvantage there so you asked you know
so I'll just tell you I think part of
the problem is marriage so I think you
get married and part of your pre
marriage counseling even though you've
been together for a bazillion years you
gotta sit down with a good pastor a good
marriage coach a good marriage counselor
and get pre-marriage counseling should
include let's get on the same page with
money and you know we need to be on the
same page with money we need to say okay
we're gonna live on a written plan that
we both agree to and that we both have a
vote on so it's not me telling you what
to do not you telling me what to do but
we're gonna get on a plan and we're
gonna work towards being debt-free why
because that leads us to be able to be
more generous and be able to go on
vacations or go out to eat and that kind
of stuff but I mean if you will just
step back and say it's tough for me to
get my roommate to not want to go out to
eat that's a different discussion than I
want to talk to my wife about we eat out
too much because when we're 80 years old
we're gonna be broke if we don't
straighten this out it's a different
discussion it really is and I know some
of you don't think it is but you're
wrong again I've read 20 25 Studies on
this and there's all kinds of
socio-economic psychological relational
data out there that matches up with my
faith belief as well which happens to be
handy but um but is it's not just this
blind thing of all day rim's is one of
those guys that believes in God
well yeah is one of those guys who
believes in God and so that's probably
if you ought to be married before you're
sleeping together I know don't but
that's just that I know that I know
something you don't like that and you
know how much I care not at all
so that's what I believe and so you
asked you're going to get that then
that's what you're gonna get so by the
way those of you that are getting
engaged or thinking about getting
married one of the best pieces of
research that I ever saw and I've read
it in
probably bred similar conclusions in
several different locations says that
before you get married if you if you
want a highly successful marriage and a
very low probability of a future of
divorce I mean it takes your divorce
rate well under 10 percent if you do
this it's amazing these four things be
in agreement on these four things money
is the big one number one thing people
fight about in marriage in relationships
is money so be in agreement on it
finding agreement on money is everything
because where you spend your money says
what you think is important and when you
think two different things are important
all the time you're never going to have
fun now if you can get to both of them
that's fine but you're never going to
have a great relationship when one of
you wants to spend like you're in
Congress and the other wants to save
everything and live in a cave and only
come out on triple coupon Thursday and
collects lint you know and so you have
to get on this you have to have this
discussion this meeting of the minds on
your value system on money and that's a
budget that's getting out of debt that's
building wealth it's putting money in
the 401k because we want to be in every
day millionaire all those kinds of
things right
being an agreement on money is one of
the things number two is being in
agreement on kids how many to have if
we're going to have them and how we're
going to treat them Ramsey's are
old-fashioned people as you can already
tell the inmates do not run the asylum
at our place we are in charge you're
smaller than me I can take you out and
make another one that looks just like
you that was my theory and so you're
going to behave and my grandkids are
being raised the same way thank you
Jesus
so there you go we're not mean or just
don't raise little hellions that think
they're in charge they're respectful and
as the three-year-old said the other day
they have consequences if they're not
what three year old says consequences
rachel cruises that's a
and vocabulary unbelievable so I have
consequences you should get your butt
busted it's a good thing you know
so how you're gonna treat your kids how
many you're gonna have if you're gonna
have them the third one is in Los are
you gonna deal with the crazy people in
each other's family and every family has
crazy in it if you don't think there's
crazy in your family it's you every
family has crazy in it somewhere how are
you going to deal with some kind of
someone who's going to violate a
boundary at some point and if you don't
have that setup you're gonna get to
experience it and it's going to be a
strain on your relationship and the last
one is being in agreement on religion
it's very unusual for people to have
long long long happy high quality
relationships that have two different
spiritual beliefs now I'm not talking
about Baptist or Methodist I'm talking
about you know one of you doesn't
believe there's a god one of you does so
on that kind of thing because it changed
your value system gives you your beliefs
and your beliefs give you your attitudes
and those give you your actions and so
your actions are always going to be in
conflict with each other when you don't
have basic belief systems and in harmony
that's what it comes down to so you need
to be in agreement on religion in-laws
kids and money if you do that prior to
marriage I'm telling you you could
almost wipe out the probability of
divorce if you want to add to it a
couple of things there's a couple other
data points if the household income
stays over 50,000 you did not have a
child prior to marriage out of wedlock
in other words you both graduate from
college these are all variables you
control
if you do that with the four things I'm
talking about your divorce rate drops
below 5% 52% of Americans end up in
divorce yeah but it's messed up
situations most of the time you can
control a lot of these variables it's
the quality of your character the
quality of your life and the quality of
your decisions and being in harmony
intentionally this is the Dave Ramsey
show